1018 elle tourne au chat pour souligner
le Mois de l'histoire des Noirs
plusieurs plateformes offrent des films
en ligne pour découvrir la réalité des
personnes afrodes c'est le cas de
l'Office national du film qui propose
gratuitement sur son site onf.ca une
section spéciale pour explorer leur
collection de films signés par des
réalisateurs
issus ou alliés des communautés noires
une vingtaine de films de 1950 à
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
des oeuvres comme
Oscar de Marie-José Saint-Pierre peu
portrait touchant d'oscarpitersun de la
Petite Bourgogne à Montréal au plus
grande scène internationales
[Musique]
animés à travers les lieux qui ont
marqué l'histoire du peuple noir la
commune mobilisation de créateurs
créatrices afrodescendante qui fait en
sorte que ben on crée nos propres
événements comme fondu au noir le
festival fondu au noir se déroule
jusqu'à dimanche c'est l'occasion de
découvrir une je vous aime des films
documentaires
fondu au noir propose également à
Montréal des tables rondes avec des
personnalités afro-canadiennes
inspirantes je trouve qu'on est vraiment
dans une belle impulsion en ce moment je
trouve même qu'il y a comme il y a
quelque chose comme une nouvelle vague
de cinéma à fond descendante
ici tout est ve aussi propose une
section spéciale pour le Mois de
l'histoire des Noirs au programme des
films et des séries comme le
documentaire afro-canada d'Henri Bardot
qui propose de décoloniser les esprits
et l'histoire en retraçant la présence
afrodescendante au Canada à travers plus
de 400 ans d'histoire ce matin ce qu'on
va faire c'est une activité sur
l'origine de la famille en salle de long
métrage par des réalisatrices afrodes
près de l'affiche au cinéma aujourd'hui
le très poétique essaie documentaires
cette maison le premier long métrage de
Myriam Charles mon histoire est à la
fois tragique et remplie d'espoir
et le documentaire le mythe de la femme
noire de la comédienne et réalisatrice
Ayana Ocean qui s'intéresse et
déconstruit les stéréotypes auxquelles
sont confrontés les femmes
afrodescendantes
avec nous ça s'arrête sur ce bon
week-end et bon cinéma ici Nadia
alexandrechassier Radio-Canada Montréal
[Musique]